皆さんこんにちは動機です
えっと僕は9
いまご荘櫂という人間なんですねですから去年ちょうど学生さんが中心になって名前
だけ出てとトークを張ってどうはずテレックスを始めるという風に聞いたときにはあ
なかなか面白いことを始める
ガン系がアクティブ開けさんいるんだなと思って同時に来年ぐらいはぜひ一度聴きに
行ってみようかなと思ってましたそういったけど今日この場にぼ
グァ
スピーカーとして存在するということはとっても夢のようなことでなかなか今イベでも
なんか信じることができない
まあほっぺがこうやってひねり高田町な状態なんですけどあのまぁなにはともあれこう
いうイベントを企画してくれた学生さんそうしてここにまあ招待してあの
トークする場を与えてくれたけどねまずは感謝したいと思いますありがとうございます
さて
では今日の僕の話を始めていきたいとおもいます
越冬道
開く
はい
皆さん
野望ってあります
ここは本来だったら夢って聞くところだと僕は思うんですけど僕は学生に行く時は指
野望って聞くんですよね
で夢っていうとなんとなくこう頑張って実現しなきゃいけないみたいなイメージがつい
てはてぃこー
シャイな日本人にはちょっと口に出すのは憚られる感じがあるんですね頂点野望って
いうとまあちょっと無理名の女だからまあ自由
好き勝手放言することはできるよねっていうことがあるんで僕は学生に花学生につく
ときはお前の野望なんだよって一の付くようにしています
で僕の野望は何か
ピューとですね
こういうことです有田誰もの思いのままに操りたい
ちょっとこれ口号と綺麗事っぽくすぎるのでもうちょっとカーンというとどんなもので
も持ってこいや
俺が重いのはを動かしてやるぜっていうことなんですね
ヤバっぽくていいでしょ
であの
でもですねこれだけ入ってるとですねなんかこれをカーなんて笑いながら言ってると
ですよなんか怪しげな怪しいやの sf 映画の悪の皇帝みたいな感じがしちゃうので
もう少し僕がこういうふうに思なった理由についてお話をしたいと思います
僕は工学部の3年生になった頃まあ
工場実習今で言うところのインターンシップですねっていうのにあの前大学に進学する
ならちょっと後十字主義ってこいやと言われていくことになりましたそれはちょうど
とある電機メーカーで今からもう年リペアですね
cd プレーヤーの開発をしている場所でしたで当時新しい
チームもたを導入した新型の機会をつくったからお前その実験手伝いやと言われて実験
をしてみまして実験したんですね
ところがあの普通に音が効いている分にはいいんですけどピット林をして曲と歌詞を
すると
ダメなんですねどこに飛んじゃって音が飛んじゃ
cd プレーヤーが音飛びをするっていう不思議な体験をしたんですけどあの日明け度
か here 人にご実験データピットを持っていくといいですね
その人はまあ忙しいってきたら机であのなんかいきなりカメラでゴリゴリゴリ時計ある
わけですよね
同地区んじゃあちょっとコンデンサー2倍にし未定って軽く言われるわけですよ
で
こんなんでいいのかなぁと思いながらコンデンサー実刑するのってコンデンサを2倍に
すると
上がらなんてことでしょうピタッと動くわけですよ
で
惚れしすげーなーと当時は思ったんですけどまぁ当時はなんで過ごすなんでそれが
こんなことは可能なのか分からず大学に戻ってきて
でちょうど大学の講義を受けたときにそれがですね西洋工学によるものであって事を
知った瞬間
あって素晴らしい
という感じでですねあのインプリンティング僕はされちゃったわけですよ
まあそんなわけで
あの制御っていう言葉をで実はいろんなことを僕はずっと携わってきたんだけどまぁ
制御ても馴染みがない人もいない簡単ちょっと話をしたいと思います
制御というのはまあ言ってしまうとなんだから近いやものを操りたいっていうことなん
ですよねだから何どんなものでも怪しいたいと思いのままに操りたいと音になるんです
がそれでダーツ言いたい近いかな
彼があった時には必ず操りたい目標も等地にあるはずです目標がなくて操りて何てこと
ないわけですよね
その時にえっとどうやったりするかっていうとまず操りたい熱いたい対象の状態を
よくよく観察をするそして熱い大目標と照らし合わせることによってどうやって相手に
働きかけていったらいいの買ったことを決めること
これが入ってしまえば制御
だから僕らは人間関係でも実は何も土生木のうち2校相手との関係はこう無意識だして
制御みたいなことをしてるわけですね
で得たとえば昔で行くとこれを歯車やゼンマイとかギアでやってるのが俗に言うから
クリーと呼ばれるやつですね
からフリーというやつですねで今の時代はですねその
ここでいうところの
制御古龍盛漁期ってやつですね人間が機械が移る仕組みというのを
数学の力アルゴリズムそしてコンピューターを支えながら基地見学者としてやっていく
のは制御工学という学問にあたります
まあそんなわけで高校大学3年生の時にこうしってインプリンティングされてしまった
僕は大学以来ずっと制御について
関わっていきたいなぁという思いのもとでずっと研究してきました
で幸いのこと2年生になって研究層は不研究室もそういう制限の研究室が入ることが
できて一番最初に行った研究がもうターン制御でしたモーターって言ってですね
なんかあの男の子なんか子供の時にミニ四駆とかではそんなことがあって何を言いまし
たらモーターなんだよって逆に言われちゃうところがあるんですけれどあの
これもよくですよねが日本で消費される消費電力の50%はモーターで消費されると
言われています
ですからそのモーターの消費電力のエネルギーを1%でも開戦すれば原子力発電所南
昆布にもあるんですよね
実はだからそんなこともあってこの10年20年省エネルギー地球環境から問題という
ことでモーターの効率改善ってのは即精力的な研究が行われて実は僕はこのずっと研究
しているんですけどその都度その都度
どんどん新しいモーターが登場していきます僕はモーターその作るのはメインじゃない
んですけどおかげでですね研究対象もどんどん制御対処
営業しなきゃいけないといっしょもどんどんどんどん変わっていってですねねあげ
カラスしかもそれに加えて幸いなことにコンピューターもこの10年20年
ありてある天井知らずでどんどん値段性能翌年の値段も下がっていくっていうことが
あったものですから
まあこう言っちゃなんですが次から次へと新しい研究テーマ降ってきてそれを新しい
コンピューターを使いながら解決していくということをずっとやってきたわけですまあ
そのおかげでモーターどんどん性能が良くなって効率もよくなって here 今まで
だったらガソリンエンジンとかいう厚で動かなきゃいけなかったものがモーター
here もう
バーで回すことができ動かすことができるようになってアプリケーションはどんどん
どんどん拡大をしていくわけです
まあ例えば家庭用のルームエアコンなんてのももうたが随分変わってしまって10年前
のエアコンだったら今も買い換えたほうがいいよという時代ですよねまあ当然電気自動
車ロボットなぁ言わずモカです
最近家もネっ子の社会書いたんですけど車はい
リッドしたら車大きくなって燃費がよくなってガソリン代から亡くなったて幸せな状態
になります
ましては最近さらにやさらに最近では飛行機についても電動化っていうのはどんどん
これから進んでいくだろうというふうに考えています
はい
でこんな感じでですねー
ずっと
野望に向かって僕は突き進んでると思ってたんですけど実はその中で一つだけ
心の中に引っかかっていることがあります
それがコレなんですよね
機械はもちろん
機械は人の指示に従っていればいいのかということです
もちろん制御すると友情は人間の指示通り動いてくれなきゃ困るわけですよね
そりゃごもっともなんですただし
人間の4市が誤ったば知事が誤っていた場合は盲目的に従っているのはいいことなん
だろうか
悪いことなんだろうか
っていうことなんですねでこれはですねなんでこんなこと思うよくなったかっていうと
まあ
白知ってる人は知ってる有名な sf 小説のアイザックアシモフのわれはロボットと
いう小説があります
os ロボットの研究ロボットし好きな人はこれ読んでなきゃもうぐですでこれは将来
社会に行こうロボットが普通に工業製品として溢れてる世の中大想定したいセーフなん
ですけどその中で
登場するロボットは必ずロボット三原則ロボット工学三原則っていうこの3つの三原則
を必ず守って生産されることになっています
その3つの三原則って簡単に紹介すると一つ目というのはロボットは人間にあの人間に
危害を加えてはいけない
また何か物事を看過することって人が違う人に危害が及ぶような状態を放置してはいけ
ない
これ大居町第1場です値段以上はその上でその1条に反しないクールにおいては人間
いうことを必ずつかなきゃいけない
そして第三乗っていうのはその1条二条に反しなキャリ
in ロボットは自らの身を守らなきゃいけないなかなか面白い
30だと思うんですねでそれ素晴らしいなと思うんですけど実際社会に適応してみると
いろんな状況があってこの惨状の隙間を縫っているのはトラブルが起きてそのトラブル
を解決するために
まあその
ロボット会社のエンジニア活躍をするというのはこの
われはロボットという話ですぜひ機会があれば読んでみてください面白いですよ
で
まさに今のこの一畳2畳の方にその話が現れてるわけですね
2条は
人間の言うことを聞かなきゃいけないんだけどまぁ第一人に危害を打っちゃいけないっ
てのはあるわけですよ
そうするとまさにこの子の中で人に盲目的に従っちゃいけないでしょ
っていうことを言ってるわけですねまぁ人形のヒューマノイドの人工知能を持った
ロボットなんてまだ先の話だって話になるんですけど実は自動ん
10の自動車最近もだんだんいろんなでもやるようになりましたね
あれってもうそれに近いですよね例えば目の前で追突しなきゃいけない
競ったり避けられないハンドルを切って隣の国ぶつかるのがいいのか
そうじゃない方がいいのかこれ究極の選択ですよね
ねふん害のことがあります
はい
結局
だんだん機械システムのレベルが上がってくるとこういうちょっと予想もしなかった
ことが起きています
これは効く従来の制御っていうのが8人間が近いの上位に存在して一方的に働きかけて
近いはそのいうことを言うとおり人が良かった
すべて何が起きても責任は人間を取り合うという前提だったわけですね
ところがそういう
人が機械を操るから
機械と人間が強調して合目的に国っていうことが求められるシステムっていうのをこれ
から僕らは使っていかなきゃいけない
だんだんそういうものは世の中に登場する
時代が近づいてきているということですよ
そうすると
目標を達成するという意味において社会と人間は対等な関係になります
人間は近いに働きかけともに近いは人間に置い間違ってるだろうとなんていう提案をし
なきゃいけない
そんな時代がやってきます
そんな時はですねどうしなきゃいけないか
まあ簡単に言えば僕らが司会を正しく操作するためにスカイノシクはちゃんと知ら
なきゃいけない
司会のことをちゃんとわかって使いこなさなきゃない同じように機械がはもう人間を
察しなきゃいけない人間に意見を言わなきゃいけない
ましてや人間を理解しなきゃいけないということになります
これは正直敵をレベルが高いですね人工知能を作る同じ話になっていきますから
だからそういった意味でこれはなかなかまだねそうそう簡単に図8できるというかまだ
逆に稼働すると僕らにとってはまだ研究する滞在山のようにあるよということになるん
ですけれどまぁでも
限定されたものに関してはこういうものはだんだん我々の身近に近いとして増えてくる
ということは多分明らかだったりします
ただし
僕らがいくら頑張って技術的に解決としても技術だけでは解決しない
技術だけでは解決しない問題があると思います
例えば
事故時の責任問題ですね例えば自動操縦している自動車をぶつかったらその責任誰が
取るのっ
っていう話ですよねこれも結構問題です
もうこれはもうだからあのむしろ人に従ってくれてた方が法律的なんなもんだよねその
人が責任てればいい
実際今でも自動車の衝突回避ブレーキの cm やりますけど cm の一番最後に1
秒か2秒絶対読むことができないずーっと中の並んだページが登場しますよねあれば
言ってしまうと
機械は人間にんげんさん人間様にアドバ
h するだけで最後の判断はあなたの責任ですよと一生懸命ていると同じですよね
あれ目
でもう一つは心の問題ですね人間の心の問題です
誓いを本当に信じることができるのかということです
僕はこの機会を信じることができるかと一番最初に体験したのは大学生の頃でですね
自動車に滑り止め防止装置 abs っての初めて搭載されたんですねで当時まああの
そんな時代でしたからブレーキってほんと abs ってなんぼのもんじゃいと俺が
ブレーキ運動が早く止まれぜなんていう
まあ若気の至りもあってですねまぁ
雪道スキーに行った時に付す騎乗スキー終わってご飯食べてお風呂入って夜中にですね
こそこそそっとガラガラのスキー場にいくんスキー場の駐車場に行くわけですね
車誰も止まってないひどい空間があるんでそこで思いっきりブレーキを踏んであの
abs が付いた車とついてないからどっちがいいかなんて実況散々やったとしました
がまあなかなか若気の至りですねそう
結果すいませんとこを誤ることになって僕は安心してそれ以来何も考えずブレーキは月
って思うようになりました
でもう一つ深刻な場合は僕今40後半もうすぐ50です
25年後の自分を考えると介護ロボットっての実は一言じゃないんですよね
25年ぐらいあったらもう出来てるかもしれないでもそのときにじゃあ介護ロボットに
自分の老後を負かしていいのか
まあ元々こういう分野でこういうことは好きでやってる人間なんだけどでもボーカル
と考えることは正直ちょっとあります
はい
まぁ結局のところですね技術的な問題もあるんですけど人と近いが新
互いに信じられるのかということは実はこれすごく大事な問題だったりします
あの
そんなん大事だと思うねこれは特にですねあの日あったあの化して技術的な問題だけ
じゃないんですよね
芸術が技術が池田解決をしても人間がそれを信じて受けられないといけない
社会的なコンセンサス3ターンは存在しないとまぁあの
残念だけどそれは受け入れないし
いうもしないそれはむしろ社会にとって何ていうのかな
あの節あの受け入れられなくて魔物のようなものもその技術になってしまうということ
になります
はい
ということでえっとここまでずっと人と近いそして制御という話をずっとしてきました
まああの
言ってしまえばもちろん技術的なことはあるんですけど
最後はやっぱり
その行為技術っていうのがあの特に新しい今今問題しているような人間と機械が対等の
関係でですね
こう渡り合っていくような傷レベルのものがだんだんの中に入ってくるということに
なると単純に技術が優れてるから ok ですねという枠には残念ながらいかない僕ら
はいくら頑張ってもそれだけじゃきっと解決しないんだろうなと思うと
これが最近にたくさん出てきます
まあそういった意味ではですねえっとぜひ皆さん
ズってですね皆さんはそういうことをいろいろと考えて社会社会適合いってもらう
だんだんできていくってこともすごく大事なんだなというふうに思ってきています
はいえっと
そうですねというところになりますで最後に
ですねー
まあ今日はイルミネーキュアハートってことであのお話をさせて頂いたわけなんです
けど正直言ってあの皆さんのハートを入れ女ねぇとするところはむしろ
もやもやっとしたものをたくさん残すようなスピーチをしちゃったんじゃないかなと
正直僕を持っています
でも半分これは確信犯ですねさっきも話したようにこういう新しい技術レベルの近いが
世の中に入ってくるとむしろ皆さんも考えてほしいんですよね
ただ単に便利なものが出てきたどうしようなんか責任があったら技術のせいだって
押し付けるのではなくてむしろそういうまあそういう使う側の人達っていうのが2技術
とどういう風に向き合うのかってこともやっぱり自分の頭で理解して知って考えて
欲しいと思いますまあそういった意味ではですね
大学の講義じゃないんですけど相手最後に宿題を出して終わりたいと
ます
それはこれです
皆さんは
機械とどう付き合っていきたいですか
そしてどうすれば機会を信じることができますか
こういうことをぜひ考えて言って頂けながら
あの新しい技術の塔技術の登場にで騒いでてほしいなぁと思います
どうもありがとうございました